there was no trepidation because as far
as I was concerned it was a pilot you
know I was well aware from having
friends that had done a lot of Pilots
most of them don't go so to me it was a
trip to Hollywood I was a fan of Jerry
Seinfeld i' had seen him perform many
times and uh I thought well this would
be fun this will be a lark and I I
thought would be a pilot and probably
that would be the end of it were you
surprised by the success yes in fact
when did you realize many at many stages
I was surprised so when we did the pilot
I think Jerry will remember this we we
at our rap party Jerry said to me what
do you think and I said there no way
there's no way you said no way yeah he
said you don't think it's good I said no
that's the problem I do think it's good
I said I think we've made a show here
that is that the primary audience for is
male 18 to about 35 that probably live
in a city you know it's you and they
don't watch TV Jerry they watch sports
but they don't watch sitcoms the number
one sitcom In America when we did our
pilot was Alf you know it's just we we
didn't look like anything else that was
on the air in the comedy world I said I
I I still I don't see what passes for a
television audience coming to our show I
was correct by the way yeah it didn't do
well
but because of that audience because it
did attract men 18 to 35 that was an
audience that Prime Time advertisers
couldn't get very easily and the fact
that they were the only ones watching
our show meant that there was always
somebody to sponsor the show well was it
Brandon tarov um his was it his wife or
that loved the I think six you got
picked up for six or something well the
story that I've always heard is we did
would be a story you did it well yeah
but you know I was not in every office
as as the mandates went down so what
came to me was we did the Pilot We Were
released from the pilot that was it we
were done that they said we're not
picking this up said that to you yeah
you got the news that it was over yes in
fact I took a Broadway show
um and then as they did back in those
days they threw it they used to throw
the dead pilots on just to fill a time
slot so on some some night at 10:30 they
threw the Seinfeld Chronicle pilot on
Rick lwin late night right is that the
guy well R Rick hadn't come in yet oh he
hadn't no cuz Rick was really he was
late night in specials and this wasn't
late night this was sitcom okay so
excuse me they
um they threw it on and I think it was
the TV Guide critic wrote it a love
letter how could NBC be so foolish this
is the newest funniest thing bah just a
love letter and tarov a loved Jerry and
was interested in doing something with
Jerry and they they said well maybe
maybe we got it wrong maybe the test
results were wrong they had no more
money to do any more episodes so this is
where Rick lwin came along he said well
I'm in charge of Summer specials I got a
ton of money money and nothing to do it
with it so make it a summer series so we
did four they called us back they added
Julia there was no Elaine in the pilot
they added Julia to the show and we our
first season pickup was four please and
they all tested like crap and they aired
them and it it had the same result as
the pilot it did not test generally very
well but it tested very well with that
key demographic and then it was time to
decide whether or not they would pick up
anep a
a season beyond that and they gave it a
midseason order but so very slowly we
kind of cobbled our way there so you
felt like you had a job I had an
intermittent job and I was stuck between
two lovers because my life and my career
were in New York but Seinfeld was all
being done out here in
LA